I came to a crash course in February and
had my mind absolutely blown I got the
opportunity to work on the eviction
prior to that I always thought that
property was an industry that was mainly
facilitated by men who had monocles in
Rolls Royces I thought you had to have
lots of money and I'm from a
working-class town I'm from Blackpool I
was on an operating table at 3 o'clock
yesterday afternoon and illegally I'm
not allowed to drive my purpose which is
to ask you one question and that is will
you allow me to be the person that you
do the financial freedom challenge with
[Applause]
now I'll live your heartburn I can see
that you're a good man and I've got I
get that question every single day no
you did I got diagnosed as having a
giant esophageal Miami oma which is also
known as a gastrointestinal stromal
tumor which is a 10 by 10 centimeter
tumor wrapped around my esophagus I've
got three kids at home I don't have a
huge amount of money how much money over
the bat winner I like like it was a big
commitment family how much everything
that was probably about 600 quid so I
went a sixth of mine went up dude
why don't you subs I will be in touch
I'll be honest with you like it [ __ ] -
how are we gonna get on there I don't
know how much time I got left
I'll be very open to come with you thank
you
my operation is they cut me open at the
front take my stomach turn it into a
sausage anyhow I'll cut your house you
serious
I'll come to blah blah all codes of
football